three months since the military seized
control of myanmar
and opposition groups show no signs of
backing down
if anything they're gearing up for more
violence announcing the formation of a
people's defense force to protect
themselves from military attacks
now a coalition of more than 200
non-governmental organizations
says the u.n security council needs to
step up
too they want an arms embargo against
the military
they say it is the least the
international community can do
words will not be enough to end this
coup by the uh
murderer in chief general minang lang
the fact that the u.n security council
allowed this man to commit genocide
in 2017 against the rohingya population
and didn't adopt a single resolution in
response
is a major contributing factor to the
climate of impunity that led
directly to this coup but so far china
and russia
have resisted calls for stronger action
we are not in favor of
of imposing sanctions and we do take it
the last result in tackling a
conflicts and the reason why we
we hold such a position is because of
the
the fact that first it will be always
ordinary people to suffer from sanctions
the security council has held at least
five meetings on the situation in
myanmar since the coup
most of them in private formal security
council statements have expressed
concern
and called for an end to the violence
backing regional efforts to mediate the
conflict
one security council diplomat tells al
jazeera they share the ngo's concerns
but that a divided security council will
help no one
that sentiment was echoed by the u.n
secretary general's spokesman
what the secretary general supports and
will continue
to support is for the urgency of a
unified
international response and that needs to
be done in close cooperation with asean
with nearly 800 dead and 40 000 people
displaced
ngos say that isn't enough kristen
salumi al jazeera
the united nations